so the other day I was talking to my
friend about what our families eat
around Christmas time my family eats
like families only chocolate that will
eat them and she was like nah sorry
buddy batter homie novel sold by the
bolita ivara
I'm will eat that so we put the 2
Mexican hot chocolate icons in a battle
to the death to settle this matter once
and for all who will win let's find out
it's either 50/50 or either not will eat
the fan or your any bottle affair I like
you about that I grew up without Willie
I'm team up Willie dad nobody that and I
feel like I've seen this in more
household why is the packaging the exact
same when he thought looks like she has
good cheese made made in Glendale yeah
well this was made to make it go homey
like that it's really good though it
smells really good look a little bit
like I thought it smells like cheese
kinky
I do love I feel like I just got a hug
oh I like that
my glasses are on TV shout-out to
whoever made this yeah I couldn't eat
then just go to town with it it's subtle
it's nice I was I guess I was expecting
something stronger I'm not gonna say
anything until I try that and it's no
more spices doesn't lead F initely has
more of a kick you could taste that oh
that's all right
damn this tastes more like the real deal
the one with the cinnamon ice would
taste more real I know I haven't tasted
this before I've tasted this this is
like spot-on my childhood I can I feel
like I could taste the Nestle Nestle
made this for people like me that don't
do spicy I feel like this one is one
that you can give like little kids with
cookies and it's like really like
Pleasant and comforting yeah who's like
a more adult art united choice number
one I like more is Ivana Oh as much as I
love a well as everywhere I gotta go
with the one that I think is vodka
because of that huge and nostalgia bump
I'm gonna go with this one right here
probably take a number two I like me
some what I think is that will eat
though this one which i think is you out
up I would drink again and again
oh well I like this one but I really
hope that this is a windy time already
right am I wrong boom well I was wrong
and I'm happy that I'm wrong
I'm a Mexican and my tongue is too I
believe that's kind of like your friend
that gets like the record deal she's
like famous and she's there for
everybody I'm gonna just mix them [ __ ]
they're gonna be mix like me you're both
hot chocolate I probably just have both